hi there Steve coffin here and it's our
fifth week of the 90 day challenge and
of this course where we're gonna take
ourselves to breakthrough level in our
language and today I want to talk about
reviewing words and phrases because
obviously we know and I've said this
before that to learn anything we need a
certain level of repetition in fact the
world renowned neuroscientist manfred
spitzer wrote in a book that i read that
to learn something we need novelty but
we also need repetition so if we only do
repetition then the brain kind of
there's this diminishing return you know
we learn less and less but there is this
saying about the brain that neurons that
fire together I don't know they form a
bridge like you got to get the neurons
working over and over and over to start
to learn something so you need
repetition so how how does reviewing
come into this all right now I'm gonna
talk to you about my experiments every
one of you has to find what works for
them there are spaced repetition systems
where they have an algorithm which says
that if you learn something now and then
in another X you know in an hour and
then in five hours and in five days and
in 15 days that there is a scientific
you know frequency or frequency of
repetition that is optimal for learning
personally I am skeptical because there
are so many factors that influence how
we absorb new information our emotions
some things are easy to learn some
things that should be difficult some
words long words complicated words for
whatever reason they stick some very
simple words just never stick or we
learn them and then we forget them again
and so I'm a bit skeptical about this
all right let's put it this way I don't
think it's simple sufficiently
beneficial
to spend a lot of time on these spaced
repetition activities that I would
sacrifice other activities because I
have a limited amount of time available
for language learning if I had eight
hours a day I would do spaced repetition
but if I have one hour a day I have to
decide am I going to be reviewing my
flashcards or am I going to be reading
or listening and so forth so to my mind
a because I don't enjoy them that much
and be because I don't think they're
necessarily that much more effective
than the enjoyable task of reading and
listening I don't do a lot of it I do
some of it and I will tell you how I do
it all right and I should point out that
because in my learning at length I very
quickly create a lot of links I've got
thousands of words links created that I
want to learn that if I were to have you
know a major effort in reviewing
flashcards even in a very you know
sophisticated spaced repetition system
that would very quickly eat up all the
time that I have available for language
learning I would find that not enjoyable
and I would not continue so what I do is
when I learn a link and and I for my
most recent languages I've been using
the many stories which in themselves
have a lot of repetition and they are
high frequency verbs then as I turn the
page of late I review so I use the
activities that we have a link and don't
forget that you can set them you because
there are five activities so there is
flashcards reverse flash cards fill in
the blanks multiple-choice and dictation
and they all have different uses
dictation was very useful for me to get
used to the Arabic writing system and
the Greek writing system but there are
times when I don't want to do dictation
I just want to review them I want the
the review for me after each page of
is an opportunity to have some
concentrated exposure to the words that
I still don't understand which I have
saved as links right so I do that right
after having read a text I will also
sometimes go to a lesson where I know
most of the words there might only be 10
or 15 words or phrases in there that I
feel I'm still struggling with rather
than reading through the whole lesson I
will simply review those words those
yellow links in our review activities
and then go away listen again so there
are many different ways that you can use
these review activities to me the review
activities are a form of concentrated
exposure so therefore I don't in my
settings for example my my link
flashcards I have all the information on
the front of the flashcard I don't want
to have to scratch my brain to try to
remember I don't think that personally I
find that that is a waste of time I
would far rather be given the meaning
all up front and it's just concentrated
reviewed now in terms of concentrated
review there are things that you can do
to enhance that activity for example
using tags so if I have trouble with
verbs of motion and Russian then I will
tag verbs of motion when I see them and
then in the vocabulary section I can
review all of the words that I tagged
for verbs of motion or if it's you know
verbs in Spanish or subjunctive or
whatever I choose to tag for then I can
have a concentrated exposure to those
words and don't forget too that with
each word you say you get example
sentences so and I find these very
useful and we now have text-to-speech
for those so that the idea to get some
concentrated exposure to things that you
have trouble remembering that's how I
use my review activity so and and of
course the fact that particularly with
the many stories in the early stages of
my learning and perhaps later on when I
want to
certain basic structures the many
stories themselves have a lot of
repetition they're a form of review so
that I wanted to share with you how I
use these activities I sometimes go to
the vocabulary section and I can look at
the srs tag or I you know tab or I can
look up it tagged some kind that I have
chosen and then have this concentrated
review until I get tired of doing it
because I can only do that for 15
minutes or so and then I lose interest
so you know I think the review is an
important part of learning a language
because it enables us to to get exposure
to content in a different way
it has the advantage to that sometimes
we're tired of reading and listening and
we want to do something else so the
review is kind of a thing that you can
do that doesn't require a lot of thought
and so it just enables us to cover some
of the same ground in a slightly
different way so I would encourage you
to do the review and to do it in the way
that suits your personal preferences and
see what works for you and it is a
feature we have an ink and make sure you
take and try to take full advantage of
it so thank you for listening and keep
on with your 90 day challenge